what's up everybody our next guest was a
sports illustrated swimsuit model who
went on to have a successful career in
both acting and business
she's also being busy being a momma of
three that's the more important job
please welcome molly sims everybody
[Music]
the back like for about a year oh cause
she told you again
anywhere so there you go well i was
going to ask you about your kids but
everybody was asked about kids first how
are you
oh i'm okay you're i was so
mommy time you're not gonna leave my
house i was so
happy to leave just my room
and my other room and the kids where are
you going mom where are you going
away away yeah far far away
to burbank to burbank it's been a lot
though especially when my mom's just
trapped home with your kids it's a lot
i'm trapped home with my kids
i hide a lot they find me in the pantry
they find me in my closet they find me
eating and drinking
they find me literally they can find me
and i have quite a big house i'm not
going to lie
they find you they sense it it's like
the other day i was talking to my
girlfriend and she was we were just i
don't know
just talking i was like behind a chair
in my room like like in like you know
crisscross freaking applesauce
like and i'm like they're like what are
you doing i'm like i'm in my own mommy
fort
so anyway all my kids do are they make
forts oh we made a fort this morning
before
we left for school every time the only
reason why that's not because my i threw
a neverland party for my kids so there's
like tp's and stuff so they're not
but usually every day is a fort i'm like
can we build something else can we call
it a castle can we call it a
you know something a tree house like can
we call it anything else no we have
forts we have forts upstairs and
downstairs we had a ford in his bed last
night
and before i left like the couch had
been taken apart
with every type of pillow sheet they
look just good questions are all over
the floor
all over the place is that super clean
have you talked about this on your
because you have a new podcast do you
talk about this stuff
we haven't emacia which i'm so excited
we have a podcast called
lipstick on the rim and it's talking
about
beauty and wellness and she's my best
friend of 17 years i met her because i
complimented her hair
um in sundance at a film festival she
was working
she was actually working for diane van
versenberger clemonaco
and we i said i don't know we kind of
connected i'm like oh call me i didn't
really mean call me
yeah i was just like call me um but
anyway she called me and
kind of kept in touch and that was 17
years ago
and we talked when we were thinking i
was going to do the the podcast by
myself and
i was like you're the one like i love to
talk to about all things beauty wellness
it's so fun we i you know to take on
something else has been
kind of crazy but it's something that i
really wanted to do i do i love
connecting people
i love you know i i love
sharing ideas and i get like you i'm i
get to work with so many amazing people
i love talking with people i love
learning about it i love it i love it
and i love
sharing what i've learned yeah and we
keep it real both of our moms recently
passed away
and you know she has a she lives in
summit new jersey
she has three little girls and i have
three so it's just
um i i love when do y'all talk about
that the loss
the loss we talk about everything i was
gonna say that a lot of people would
probably
especially this past year but so many
people have lost people we talk a lot we
um i work with a woman named claire
bidwell um she lost both her parents
one at 17 and the other one when she was
in her early 20s
all about grief and it just really helps
and i
you know i love having those real
conversations because i think
so many people like oh how do you look
like that or what do you do and
you know i work at it and it's hard and
i have
you know a crazy background with
modeling and you know just you know body
dysmorphia and like all of that that you
know a lot of people don't know
because you know i'm not really gonna
open that up but i decided to with these
conversations because
i do think it's the perfect platform for
it it's the perfect platform and
you know things don't come easy you know
i do have to work for it i hate when
i'll
ask someone like oh what did you do and
like oh i had hamburgers and french
fries and
you know i'm like no you didn't
but um no but i definitely and i love
you know i love doing with her you know
and
it's been fun we also got to uh talk to
a girl named it's me tanks
wait what do you know team no oh my god
you guys have to follow her her name is
christina her name is it's me tanks and
she talks boys
botox and rich mom culture and you just
have to like she pokes fun at it
oh yeah okay okay it is phenomenal
phenomenal well everybody molly's
podcast is called lipstick on the rim
you've got to check it out
it's available now wherever you listen
to your podcast yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever